schönen guten Abend herzlich Willkommen
zu ZDF heute live schön dass ihr dabei
seid großratier heute in fünf
Bundesländer Ermittler sind gegen ein
mutmaßliches schleusernetzwerk
vorgegangen fünf Frauen und Männer aus
Syrien wurden festgenommen sie sollen
mehr als 100 Menschen aus ihrem
Heimatland mit echten Pässen von
Landsleuten ausgestattet und so unter
anderem per Flugzeug nach Deutschland
gebracht haben dafür sollen jeweils
7000€ gezahlt worden sein 16000€ Bargeld
und Gold im Wert von mehr als
200.000 € wurden ebenfalls
beschlagnahmt ja das mag ein Erfolg
gegen schleuserkriminalität sein und
gleichzeitig ist es wahrscheinlich nur
ein Tropfen auf den heißen Stein denn
gerade bringen wahrscheinlich Schleuser
Menschen durch die Wüste in Nordafrika
oder schicken Sie auf ein Boot das dann
aufs Mittelmeer hinausfährt machtlos
gegen Schleuser darüber wollen wir heute
Abend sprechen und zwar mit den mit Lars
wentendland das ist der Vorsitzende der
Gewerkschaft der Polizei zuständig für
die Bundespolizei und mit dem
migrationsexperten luouigi akili ihr
könnt euch gerne an diesem Stream
beteiligen schreibt in den Chat rein
eure Fragen eure Kommentare oder schickt
uns eine E-Mail wir starten jetzt gerne
mit Lars Wendland schönen guten Abend
ein wunderschönen guten Abend her
wentendland ich habe es gerade eingangs
gesagt diese Razia war das jetzt ein
großer Schlag oder ein kleiner
Fisch also ich denke mal es war schon
ein großer Schlag allerdings ist das ja
sie haben es ja auch erwähnt die Leute
sind mit dem Flugzeug gekommen das heißt
sie sind ausgestattet worden mit Pässen
ist natürlich eine andere Situation und
auch ein anderes Verfahren als das was
derzeit in aller Munde ist nämlich
Grenzkontrollen Ja oder Nein an der
polnischen tschechischen
österreichischen oder Schweizer Grenze
jetzt will die Innenministerin sie haben
ja gerade angesprochen eben doch diese
stationären Grenzkontrollen nennt man
sie sie war ja lange dagegen wird das
die Schleuserbanden überhaupt
interessieren die Frage ist was wir als
Auftrag bekommen als Bundespolizei wenn
man stationäre statische Grenzkontrollen
macht sind wir davon überzeugt hilft es
äh uns insgesamt in Deutschland gar
nicht
wir fordern als Gewerkschaft der Polizei
flexible Grenzkontrollen auch an der
Grenzlinie aber so dass wir
unberechenbar sind nämlich niemand weiß
wann wir wo unsere Kontrollen machen
wenn wir statische Kontroll
Kontrollstellen haben
24 Stunden rund um die Uhr dann sind wir
berechenbar und dann muss man nicht
unbedingt über den Übergang fahren
sondern kann vielleicht auch nebenher
laufen ähm die deutsch-polnische Grenze
ist natürlich auch mit einem Fluss
gesegnet mit dem mit der nice oder der
oder und die nece hat derzeit teilweise
nur 20 cm das heißt oben auf der Brücke
steht die Bundespolizei und unten laufen
die Schleuser mit ihren Migranten rüber
mhm die Innenministerin selbst ist ja
auch nicht hundertprozentig überzeugt
von der Maßnahme hat ja heute gesagt man
muss dann auch mal selber schauen was es
bringt ähm warum lässt sie diese
Kontrollen dann
vorbereiten ja ich habe zum Schluss
gehört dass sie auch nur flexible
Kontrollen haben möchte es ist immer die
Frage der Begrifflichkeit
wie gesagt stationär stationäre und
statische Kontrollen sind aus unserer
Sicht nicht richtig
jetzt muss man gucken
der Druck ist sehr hoch nicht nur bei
der bundesinnenministerin sondern alle
Länder bei uns in Deutschland unsere
Bundesländer haben natürlich hohen Druck
und jetzt ist die Frage wie die Politik
sich generell aufstellt für uns ist aber
wichtig dass wir nicht nur die Migranten
aus diesen Autos befreien
und dann zuleiten können der
Ausländerbehörde sondern für uns ist ja
auch wichtig dass wir den Schleusern
habhaft werden und da ist es enorm
wichtig nicht nur den Fahrer sozusagen
oder den Schlepper den letzten zu
bekommen sondern wir wollen ja die
schleusernetzwerke so wie es eben in
ihrem Bericht auch heute aus einem
Flughafen Verfahren geworden ist mhm
gehen wir noch mal gedanklich an die
Grenze ähm da ist ja auch immer von
schleierverandung die Rede wo sind da
die Grenzen dieses
Mittels wir dürfen in Deutschland nach
dem bundespolizeigesetz innerhalb von 30
km äh von der grenzkontrollinie Weg äh
unsere sogenannte schleierfahnung machen
das ist das Mittel was uns der schengler
grenzkodex derzeit hergibt und
von daher dürfen wir innerhalb dieses 30
km Korridors äh unsere Aufgaben
erledigen wir als Gewerkschaft der
Polizei forderten schon lange eine
Änderung der Gesetzesvorhaben nämlich
auf 50 km auch das ist ja leider noch
nicht passiert und das
bundespolizeigesetz ist ja leider auch
noch nicht verabschiedet worden da
springt ja im Moment auch das
Bundesministerium der Justiz mit Rum und
auch da muss man gucken wenn wir
wirklich effektiv arbeiten sollen muss
man uns das Handwerkszeug geben mm jetzt
schreibt live Trend auf Youtube
Grenzschutz wie USA Kanada Australien
das ist so einfach ähm was sind noch mal
die Besonderheiten die besonderen
Gegebenheiten im deutschen Recht im
EU-Recht wir sind hier in Europa wir
sind nicht äh an der ich sag mal USA
mexikanischen Grenze wir können hier
keinen Grenzzaun errichten und das
wollen wir auch gar nicht Europa ist
eine Errungenschaft
wo ich sage ich persönlich auch sage ich
möchte ganz gerne auch in meine
Nachbarstaaten reisen ohne kontrolliert
zu werden das ist eine Errungenschaft in
Europa
die finde ich enorm und die darf man
auch nicht zerstören und und der Druck
der Migranten ist so hoch gerade
allerdings können wir das auch nicht mit
solchen ich sag mal Mitteln wie sie
jetzt da gerade dargestellt worden sind
wir können sie nicht begrenzen das
einzige was man machen kann aus unserer
Sicht aus Sicht der Gewerkschaft der
Polizei dass man Zentren baut an den
Außengrenzen da müsste die EU anfangen
und vielleicht auch mit dem
flüchtlingswerk der UN dem
UNHCR prüfen welche Möglichkeiten an
unseren außen bestehen dort Zentren zu
schaffen um eben dann eine legale
Einreise nach Europa zuzulassen mm dazu
schreibt jetzt ren auf Facebook solange
die Herkunftsländer nicht mitspielen
können wir und damit meint er die EU nur
reagieren und nicht agieren was sagen
sie dazu da hat er nicht ganz Unrecht
aber deswegen habe ich ja gerade auch
gesagt wir müssen an den Außengrenzen
stehen und dann ist es eigentlich auch
völlig egal was für ein Herkunftsland
wenn wir ihn erst dann reinlassen oder
die Menschen reinlassen wenn sie
wirklich
ähm das Recht haben reinzukommen dann
haben wir auch die Möglichkeit zu sagen
er ist legal in Europa und dann ist egal
ob er aus welchem herkunfland er auch
kommt
wir haben vorher dann unsere Grenze die
den Schutz unsereer Außengrenze und ich
glaube da ist der Ansatz genau richtig
derzeit mm jetzt gehen wir noch mal an
die deutschen Grenzen führen wir uns mal
die Situation vor Augen ihre Kolleginnen
ihre Kollegen treffen eben an der Grenze
auf Migranten was passiert dann
genau na es wird gefragt wo sie
herkommen ähm wenn die Sprachbarriere da
ist wird es mit Händen und Füßen gemacht
in der Regel wird man auch sofort
erkennen oder auch man gibt sich zu
erkennen wo sie herkommen und was sie
wollen in der Regel 90 bis 95% an der
polnischen Grenze sagen sie möchten
einen schutzersuchen stellen also ein
Asylantrag stellen und dann werden sie
mitgenommen zur Dienststelle sie werden
dort bearbeitet sie werden überprüft das
heißt polizeifchlich überprüft und wenn
dann wir mit unseren Abarbeitung fertig
sind werden sie wie auf freien Fuß
gelassen und werden dann zur
Aufnahmestelle äh in Brandenburg ist es
die Zentrale Aufnahmestelle in
eisenhütenstadt gebracht und dort werden
sie weiter bearbeitet das Asylverfahren
macht das Bundesamt für Migration und
Flüchtlinge da sind wir als
Bundespolizei dann raus das heißt um das
noch mal ganz klar zustellen ähm mit
diesen Maßnahmen mit dieser stationären
Grenzkontrolle die jetzt gerade
diskutiert wird da wird nur eben die
Illegalität etwas reduziert es reduziert
sich aber dadurch nicht die Anzahl der
Flüchtlinge die an die Grenze kommen und
über die Grenze kommen nein die Anzahl
wird sich definitiv nicht reduzieren wir
werden höchstens Vorort an der
Grenzkontrollstelle aus unserer Sicht
wie gesagt flexibel werden wir die
Menschen aufnehmen und frag fragen wo
kommen sie her was machen Sie hier wo
wollen sie hin und wenn man dann sagt
wir haben ein schutzersuchen also Asyl
dann müssen wir sie auch dort aufnehmen
genau das gleiche was jetzt auch im
Innenland passiert bei der
schleierfahung jetzt sagt ihr Kollege
tegger von der Deutschen
Polizeigewerkschaft sie sind von der
Gewerkschaft der Polizei zwei
unterschiedliche der findet den Vorstoß
von Nancy fer eigentlich gut der sagt
sogar das kommt zu spät also wie wie
geht das dass die eine
Polizeigewerkschaft sagt finden wir gut
und die andere nicht
so wir sagen wir möchten keine
stationären statischen Grenzkontrollen
Herr Tagger war immer der Meinung zu
sagen wir brauchen stationäre
Grenzkontrollen wir sagen wir sind für
die Kollegen und Kollegen da diese
laufen derzeit wirklich am Limit egal ob
wir sie jetzt mit flexiblen
Grenzkontrollen oder in der
schleierfahnung haben wir haben sehr
viel Personal hier was wirklich am Limit
läuft und jetzt auch noch stationäre
Grenz Kontrollen
dazu muss man sich überlegen wenn ich
die stationär mache dann habe ich
24 Stunden rund um die Uhr dort einen
Trupp stehen
mit bestimmt fünf bis Zeh Leuten in
einer Schicht bei fünf Schichten
in einem fünf Schichtsystem muss man
überlegen das sind 50 Leute die ich für
eine Kontrollstelle brauche ähm wir
sagen das Personal ist nicht da um das
zu machen und deswegen sagen wir
flexibel äh da könnten wir gerade noch
so mitgehen dass das äh auch personell
zu stemmen ist allerdings kriegen wir
das auch nicht auf Dauer hin ich weiß
nicht und die Gewerkschaft der Polizei
ist sich derzeit auch nicht sicher wo
wir das Personal denn hernehmen sollen
wir sehen ja auch dass das die
Landespolizei auch mit Kräften vor Ort
ist in einer sogenannten
schleierverhandlung die Bundespolizei
derzeit unterstützt und selbst bei der
Landespolizei ob es Sachsen ist oder in
Brandenburg haben wir im Moment sehr
starke Bedenken dass wir das mit dem
Personal was derzeit da ist überhaupt
schaffen können auch auf Dauer das heißt
also wir brauchen europäische Lösung wir
brauchen auch um schleusernetzwerke zu
zerschlagen effektives Arbeiten und dazu
brauchen wir Personal nämlich
Spitzenpersonal Fachpersonal da hat die
Polizei die Bundespolizei zumindest in
den letzten Jahren nicht unbedingt ihre
Hausaufgaben gemacht da hoffen wir aber
dass wir dort sind wir in Gesprächen
dass das in der nächsten Zeit besser
jetzt fragt sich pyofrieg was diese
stationären Kontrollen an an der
polnischen Grenze bringen sollen er
meint dass dadurch doch im Grunde
genommen die Arbeit der Schleuser sogar
noch erleichtert wird W wenn diese
Kontrollen wenn Personal eben an an
diese fixen Punkte gebündelt wird das
ist das was ich eben gesagt habe wir
müssen unberechenbar bleiben und das
funktioniert eben nur wenn wir flexibel
sind die schleierfandung die wir sowieso
schon haben mit flexiblen Möglichkeiten
an den grenzkontrollpunkten unsere
Kontrollen durchzuführen dann sind wir
unberecht und dann hab haben wir auch
mehr Möglichkeiten dem Schleuser zu
sagen hallo hier Stopp denn er wusste ja
nicht dass wir da jetzt quasi in der
nächsten 10 Minuten auftauchen und
unsere Kontrolle machen vielleicht noch
ein letzter kommentar von David wir
hatten 8 Jahre Zeit und es ist nichts
passiert Zentren an den Außengrenzen zu
Bauern zu bauen wird Jahre dauern er
schreibt wir brauchen jetzt schnelle und
wirksame Maßnahmen wie könnten die
aussehen das ist eine politische Frage
die ich nicht bew en kann denn wir sind
für die Kolleginen und Kollegen da ich
hätte jetzt keine sofortige Lösung denn
wir können nicht anders außer nach Recht
und Gesetz arbeiten die Bundespolizei
muss jedem der ein schutzersuchen
Stellen reinlassen und weiterleiten an
das Bundesamt für Migration und
Flüchtlinge der deutsche Rechtsstaat ist
so aufgebaut dass nur das BAM Bundesamt
für Migration und Flüchtlinge diese
Maßnahmen überprüfen kann und auch die
Entscheidung treffen kann die
Bundespolizei selber ist bei dieser
Geschichte raus wir dürfen diese
Entscheidung gar nicht treffen Herr
wentendland ich danke Ihnen sehr für
ihre Einschätzung und dass sie uns die
Situation an den Grenzen noch mal
geschildert haben vielen Dank tschüss
Ihnen auch einen schönen Abend danke
schön ja und wir gehen direkt weiter wir
sprechen jetzt mit dem italienischen
migrationsexperten Luigi akili schönen
guten
Abend guten Abend Herr Kili bei der
Razia heute morgen ich habe es ja
eingangs gesagt wurde eine Gruppe von
syern festgenommen die Syrer nach
Deutschland gebracht haben sollen ist
das eine ein lukratives Geschäft oder
ist das auch mehr in dem in der
Situation eine Form von Solidarität oder
am Ende
beides es ist beides natürlich zum einen
das Geschäft da fließt ja viel
Geld aber es ist natürlich auch eine Art
von
Solidarität viele
Flüchtlinge nicht viele Flüchtlinge sind
involviert im Schmuggel in der
Schleusung und sie machen das auch um
ihren
m und den Menschen und ihren Landsleuten
zu helfen weil es keine legalen
Möglichkeit der Mobilität gibt es ist
natürlich nicht nur
Solidarität da gibt's sicherlich
auch diese Zuneigung gegenüber den
eigenen Landsleuten beim
Menschenschmuggel zum Teil
zumindest die Beschuldigten sind selbst
asylbwerber ist das ein klassisches
Muster das geflüchtete dann auch selbst
zu Schleusern
werden ja das
stimmt
viele Menschen die ich getroffen habe
und das gilt auch für andere Forscher
für mich selbst die haben festgestellt
dass die
meisten dass die meisten Schleuser
ursprülich mal Flüchtlinge waren die
haben selber Asyl
beantragt was ist der Grund für dieses
verschwimmen der
Linien die Flüchtlinge selbst kennen ja
die Strecken die man entlang laufen muss
die haben selber Erfahrung die
wissen die wissen wo man über die Grenze
kommt die kennen die Leute die haben die
Verbindungen und die können dann die
Schleuser mit der mit den Menschen vor
Ort
zusammenbringen sie kennen sich aus sie
kennen auch die Sprache in viel
Fällen und of haben sie den gleichen
Hintergrund der Leute die sie
schmuggeln also in Deutschland sind
viele schmuckler
syer und die machen das für ihre
Landsleute dazu können wir uns kurz mal
eine Verzeigung dazu können wir uns kurz
eine Grafik anschauen woher die meisten
mutmaßlichen Schleuser kommen die in
diesem Beispiel jetzt Menschen nach
Deutschland bringen wir schauen uns das
kurz
an auch durch schleierfandung entlang
der Grenzen wurden laut
Bundesinnenministerium dieses Jahr
bisher 1400 mutmaßliche Schleuser
festgenommen wer die Tatverdächtigen
sind zeigen diese Zahlen für die erste
Jahreshälfte unter den Festgenommenen
sind 150 Ukrainer und 148 Syrer sowie 89
Türken 65 deutsche und 56 Afghanen
andere mutmaßliche Schle
a Georgien Moldau rumenien Russland oder
Usbekistan wir erklären Sie sich das
warum sind jetzt gerade aktuell Ukraine
Syrien Türkei auf Platz auf den ersten
drei
Plätzen also bei der Türkei ist das
nicht so
überraschend den da gibt's einfach eine
ethnische
Verbindung und oft ist es so dass die
Schleuser und die Migranten den gleichen
Familienhintergrund haben oder ischen
Hintergrund und Syrien ist ja da in der
Nähe und da gibt's ja viele Menschen die
aus ihrem Land fliehen und da ist es
nicht überraschend dass die Türkei ein
wichtiges Transitland
ist
also die Syrer und die
Türken die haben vielfältige
Verbindungen und die kennen Menschen auf
der ganzen Welt und das macht einfacher
Leute zu
schleuen
interessanterweise gibt es auch viele
Ukrainer die aber doch mit legalen
Status reinkommen
können die Ukraine war oft ein
Transitland also die Schleuser aus der
Ukraine die helfen Menschen durch ihr
Land durch zu laufen und viele Ukrainer
wollen auch dem whrdienst entgehen in
ihrem Land deswegen ist es so dass viele
Schleuser also ich wer schon gesagt da
gibt's edische Verbindungen viele
Schleuser sind eben auch involviert in
das Schmuggeln von ihren eigenen
Landsleuten und in den europäischen
Mitgliedsländern gibt es sehr viele
Ukrainer und da gibt's aber auch nicht
Ukrainer wie z.B Roma oder
Nigerianer da gibt es nicht dies
aber die benutzen eben auch die Dienste
dieser ukrainischen
Schmuggler sie haben mit vielen
Schleusern gesprochen haben da viele
Einblicke bekommen noch mal insbesondere
vielleicht über das Verhältnis von
Schleusern und Flüchtenden was können
sie uns da
berichten was ich
überraschend Studien über Schleuser war
die
Komplexität in dem Verhältnis zwischen
Schleusern und
Migranten die meisten Schleuser die ich
interviewte die sind
stolz sie sagen sie machen etwas
moralisch wichtiges dch dass du den
Menschen helfen zu fliehen und sie
machen einen Gewinn
damit
normalerweise ist es ja schwierig über
die Grenz zu
kommen also es ist ein Widerspruch im
europäischen System wen man illegal die
Grenze überschreitet und dann Asyl
beantragt bestimmte Kategorien von
Migranten wie z.B politische
Flüchtlinge und die Daten
zeigen dass
sie nicht beim ersten Mal erfolgreich
sind und manchmal werden die zwei
dreimal über die Grenzen
geschmuggelt und was libien
angeht da kann man sagen dass es normal
ist dass Kriminelle
of viert werden und sich ein Stück von
dem Geschäft
abschneiden die Migranten die ich
getroffen hab in
Interviews war dass sie zum Teil eben
auch diese Meinung die die
menschenchmuck von sich haben auch
Teilen es heißt Schleuserbanden würden
Milliarden verdienen wie professionell
ist dieses Geschäft organisiert und wer
verdient da alles noch
mit das ist eine sehr gute Frage es ist
eine Tatsache dass sehr viel Geld da
verdient
wird und die
Polizei die Politiker und so
weiter sagen dass weil viel Geld FE das
große
tatsächlich ist es so dass in meinen
Studien und andere Studien zeigt es auch
dass es normalerweise nicht diese großen
Organisationen gibt es sind eher kleine
Gruppen die miteinander in Partnerschaft
treten um ihre Arbeit zu machen
und viel von dem Geld
geht nicht in die Taschen der schmugler
selbst viel von dem Geld wird wieder neu
verteilt in legalen illegalen
Märkten z.B gibt es viele Leute die
Taxifahrer
rekrutieren für den
Weitertransport oder Busgesellschaften
z.bpi also diese Gewinne der
Schleuser die werden wieder ausgegeben
für
Logistikdienstleistungen Taxifahrer
bringen in der Türkei z.B auf die Leute
von den
Stadtzentren zu irgendwelchen Punkten wo
sie auf die Boote gehen und da gibt's
noch einen illegalen Markt wo auch Geld
hinfließt die Schleusung für Menschen
besteht aus kleinen
Organisationen es gibt aber auch große
Fische die davon
profitieren dass die Schleusung
kann nur passieren wenn man irgendwie
von den Leuten die Macht haben in dem
Territorium wo man Leute schmugelt dass
man da das Recht bekommt von
drogenschmugcklern oder
Mafiaorganisationen oder ähnlichem und
diese großen Fische die bekommen Geld
die nehmen nämlich Geld von den
Schleusern dafür dass sie ihnen erlauben
Leute durch deren Territorium zu
schleusen ich schau mal in den Chat Tina
schreibt das Asylrecht muss völlig neu
überdacht und auf die heutige Situation
angepasst werden oder Revo fragt warum
verstärkt man Frontex nicht an der
Außengrenze also was muss ihrer Meinung
nach passieren
wie kann man diese Schleuserbanden
zurückdrängen und eben auch ja ein Stück
weit
bekämpfen eine gute Frage da gibt es
nicht die eine Maßnahme die wirkt
aber was so weit probiert worden ist war
auch
erfolgreich die politischen Maßnahmen
gegen
Schleusung die konzentriert sich auf
diplomatische oder
sicherheitspolitische Dinge also Frontex
z.B und das ist die falsche Lösung also
es war bis jetzt nicht
erfolgreich
wir müssen das System neu aufstellen vor
kurzem war so dass die italienische
Ministerpräsidentin georia Moni sie
sagte wir müssen die Leute stoppen
überhaupt auf die botte zu
gehen statt dass wir sie in Europa
umverteilen und das ist genau das
wenn man die Leute blockiert dann müssen
sie eben Schleuser nutzen das ist das
Problem statt die
Schleusung zu
stoppen sollte
man die Situation versuchen zu
kontrollieren
in
Europa muss revidiert werden man muss
eine gute Lösung für das dublinabkommen
Finden es gibt schon
einige gute Vorschläge für ein
gemeinsames Asylsystem in Europa es ist
nicht einfach
aber kurz es gibt viele kurzfristige
Lösungen die politisch einfach nicht
akzeptabel sind
deswegen bleiben wir bei diesen maßn
Namen die eine selbsterfüllende
Prophezeiung sind also wir beklagen uns
über die Situation die wir selber mit
unseren Maßnahmen kreieren das heißt
wenn ich sie richtig verstehe ist es ein
pledoier mehr Wege zu legaler Migration
zu ermöglichen kommen wir vielleicht zum
Schluss zu unserer Eingangsfrage zurück
aus ihrer Sicht ist Europa machtlos
gegen
Schleuser
also nicht
machtlos wir gehen einfach nur in die
falsche
Richtung ob das absichtig oder
unabsichtig passiert das kann ich nicht
bewerten aber im Interesse der
europäischen
Mitgliedstaaten geht es nicht um den
Kampf gegen die Schleusung sondern Kampf
gegen die
Immigration
wir externalisieren praktisch
diese Verantwortung für Asylverfahren an
libien Tunesien und so weiter und das
funktioniert langfristig
nicht die Migranten werden dadurch nur
auf andere Ruten
geführt es wird schleußer geben solange
es eine Nachfrage nach diesen
Dienstleistungen gibt das ist ganz
klar es ist ja ganz klar was in Syrien
passiert trotz der Maßnahmen von Ländern
wie Italien trotzdem sie ein Abkommen
mit Tunesien abgeschlossen haben aber
das wird nicht funktionieren langfristig
vielleicht kurzfristig aber langfristig
bringt das gar
nichts wenn wir eine Lösung finden
wollen müssen wir mehr legale Kanäle
finden für die Immigration wenn wir das
tun werden wir nicht machtlos sein
Gegenüber der Schleusung es ist ein
weites Feld wir könnten uns noch sehr
sehr lange unterhalten lassen Sie uns
das Gespräch an dieser Stelle beenden
Herr Kil ich danke Ihnen herzlich machen
sie es gut
tschüss vielen Dank ja und damit würden
wir uns für heute verabschieden vielen
Dank für eure Fragen eure Kommentare wir
sehen uns hoffentlich bald wieder ZDF
heute live
tschüss